canon bridge of spirits is a rich
compelling tale of fantasy and adventure
with themes of trauma and loss of
forgiveness
and yes it's full of fast-paced action
and breathless battles with supernatural
foes
but the first thing that hits you when
you see it is the beauty of a debut game
from a small but passionate team at
ember labs
and how the stunning animation of its
lush magical world pulls you into a
journey
of a spirit guide trying to save a
village haunted by restless souls
but why not let you see it for yourself
here's our next official selection
cana bridge of spirits
look penny ground yourself
feel the energy of the mountain
[Music]
draw on its power
[Music]
two the emblem is a really small studio
we have a background in film and
animation uh we got our start doing
visual effects for
[Music]
films
and then from there we go into doing a
lot of animated work for commercials
[Music]
in between commercial projects we would
always siphon off some time to learn new
things and you know be a little creative
[Music]
and over time you know we decided that
wow we have a real passion for games
um and we wanted to throw our hat into
the ring with our first project canaan
something tells me you did not come to
our village looking for forest creatures
hello spirit i seek passage to the
sacred mountain shrine
we've been playing games our whole lives
together as brothers um
and the action adventure games are sort
of what we play together and we
also enjoy yeah
[Music]
we kind of had this idea of the rot
being kind of a force of nature that was
maybe working against you was kind of
the enemy initially and then i kind of
had the
thought to flip it where the rock all
become your companions
and that's when we kind of like found
that we we had something kind of unique
i opened a lot of cool mechanics
especially with the puzzles in the game
[Music]
[Music]
you know with film you can just put the
camera where you want it you can tell
you can
you have complete control over what
they're seeing when they're seeing it
how they're seeing it
in games all that goes out the window so
communicating
ideas or themes to the player is a lot
more difficult to be found yeah
[Music]
you have to be really sort of crafty in
how you're getting communication to the
player
especially when it's trying to do it
through gameplay and not just like
always through cutscene
one of tara's memories i should see that
reason
we love creating immersive experiences
and we tried to really
think about atmosphere and tone a lot
when we're in on the game development
side
[Music]
storytelling and atmosphere is a big
part of our
traditional medium to the film
aesthetics
just having the world be something you
want to sit down and explore and be a
part of
was a goal of ours from the beginning
having a nice uh team of really great
animators who have worked together i
think was paramount in terms of pulling
off some of the
storytelling we want to do with the game
[Music]
we're actually making like a 45 minute
animated
movie inside of a game hi we're really
proud of the team
a lot of them come from the visual
faction animation background and kind of
like convert their skill sets from
the film and animation background into
developers on the game side
during the process of making the game we
also were introduced to
the musical group called sudamani and we
actually you know jason myself went over
to bali to do
recording for the soundtrack
[Music]
one of the things that's grown out of
that relationship is day wise
is the composer but his daughter aiu is
actually the voice of kana my name's
kayna
what are you two doing out here she's
never done any voice acting but she fit
right in
it's okay you have to go now
you know we wanted to make a game that
would just excite us if we saw it you
know sometimes we would see the trend oh
yeah that's that game is awesome yeah
so as difficult as as it has been it's
also
very rewarding because it's like
something that we were very proud of
something we want to pick up ourselves
you must move on
um
the path of a spirit guide is a lonely
[Music]
one